What about when your Objective-C
code is consuming Swift errors?
Let's take a look at how a Swift method
that throws would be interpreted by
Objective-C.
Here I have a project whose main
function is in Objective-C.
The project includes a Swift class with
the following error throwing function,
this function throws
an error of type MyError.
Notice that in order to expose
this enum to Objective-C,
I mark it with the attribute @objc.
Now we're going to call this
function from our main function.
We've got a variable to hold our error
and an instance of SomeSwiftClass.
Now let's call our Swift function.
Notice that Xcode gives
us the option to call
doSomethingThatMightFailAndReturnError.
AndReturnError has been
appended to the method name and
now we have the option to pass
an error parameter into the method.
Cool, that's not that surprising.
It's pretty much the reverse of what
we saw going from Objective-C to Swift.
Now let's see how the error
might be processed.
We'll write a log statement and
in that statement we'll grab the domain
and code from the error that's returned.
And then if we run it,
here's what we see in the console.
So the domain and error code are
automatically populated, which is super.
Unfortunately, if you want to know the
value of the enum member that goes with
that code, like WeirdReason or
TypicalReason that you can see here,
you can't access it directly
from your Objective-C code.
You have to look back at
the enum implementation.
It was no coincidence that I wrote
the MyError enum to be of type Int.
Let's not forget that enums in
Objective-C can only hold ints.
That means that if you have a Swift
error that you want to be consumed by
Objective-C it has to be of type int.
Unfortunately, that means
that enums like this one,
that provide information about
the errors right in their raw values,
can't be translated to Objective-C.
Even though NS errors aren't as spiffy
as Swift errors, the takeaway here
is that the interrupt for error
handling is mostly handled for you.
NS errors just work in Swift.
And all you have to do to get your Swift
errors to work in Objective-C is mark
them with the attribute @objc, and
make sure they have an integer type.